hello and welcome to the Internet
unfortunately there is no show this week
but the rest of the world does not stop
randomly in our absence like a General
Motors vehicle so our obligation to
bring you last week's news remains now
we are taping this on Sunday May 18th
because frankly we didn't feel like
coming in to the studio and I week off
that's what vacation means but but we
sat down and we came up with some
predictions that seemed fairly safe for
the news of next week that we can look
back on as a last week so you get the
point so it he goes um our top stories
last week LeBron James dunked a
basketball forcefully several times in
front of Miami's largest collection of
Jessica easy bet right
that that was just the first one was
easy additionally an old rich man last
week was accused of racism or sexism and
while trying to explain them away only
seemed more racist I'm not sure who that
was but we haven't heard much from
Donald Trump in a while so I'm guessing
it was him in in international news last
week's situation in the Middle East was
let's say complicated those were all
Gibby's let's do some more difficult
speculative news in Mexico
congratulations to the drug cartels
which which last week celebrated killing
their one millionth bystander oh also oh
you regretted laughing at the setup
there didn't you
you wait for the punchline or you get
burnt that's a huge teachable moment for
you also a bit of a shock from the
Vatican as the Pope joined tinder and
listed his statuses down for whatevs
meanwhile he's a new pope he said he's a
refreshing change meanwhile in
Washington America's most punk-rock
senator demanded answers about the four
Americans lost in Fugazi where are they
where are they it's been ages since
their last album and Hillary Clinton has
some answering to do in in Sporting News
shocking news as another NFL player came
out last week and then every other NFL
player came out it turns out the NFL has
been entirely gay all this time yeah I
know
yes in business news GM is now recalling
cars made by other companies just for
even the playing field in entertainment
news and actor pretending to be a war
hero was applauded for his bravery um
that we all thank him for his pretend
service and a circus frightened as many
children as it delighted that's not so
much news as just a very safe bet and in
your personal news you canceled on your
aunts Memorial Day cookout tomorrow
because there's no way you're going to
that thing no way finally tonight the
winning Powerball numbers were 13 34 745
51 and 20 now I realize that is a bold
prediction to have made a week in
advance but holy imagine if we
nailed that one
just
imagine that
thank you so much for watching this week
feel free to watch more videos here on
our YouTube channel or tweet at us at
last week tonight to tell us how
accurate our predictions were we'll be
back next Sunday night with a new
episode at 11:00 p.m. on HBO unless of
course we nailed the lottery numbers in
which case off and we will see you
never look we don't need you
we're rich we're rich